when you see
these wack rapper lists i know you
talked about the uh the gilly thing
before but when you see these lists
you're always on the list
how do you genuinely feel about that
oh that's that's why that's basically
why he got a gun came out you know i'm
saying
that's why i had to get back in my bag
you know what i'm saying
uh i i don't i don't i don't like it you
know what i'm saying like
i think i'm a
comedian rapper but
you know
i think
it goes back to the just
just saying anything even if it ain't if
you don't if it don't rhyme or it's just
crazy or just playing that role so like
you were playing it like i think what
people what you said earlier like you
were legitimately playing that character
and doing well yeah yeah right right
so here yeah so that's that's why i'm
here to change it that's why i'm
literally here right now
in your face so you're like yo i'm tired
of these lists so outside of your guy
with the six cats and the four dogs and
the children ah fall balls and that's
how the phone and the sony acid
that was god damn that was also a
motivating factor for you to get back in
your bag like i'm tired of this [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah for sure for sure yeah i i i
think i didn't put too much work in
a lot of people don't know i i am a
battle rapper i started off from the
hip-hop shop that's why i met marshall
if i was a whack rapper they wouldn't
never put me in d12 because d12 was a
hand-picked click
of battle rappers yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying so
um yeah so
you know i think you know once we got in
the industry
we kind of like had to find our way you
know what i'm saying like all that [ __ ]
was kind of like an accident even the
shower cap started off as a joke and
then it just began they just stuck this
[ __ ] with me
i mean it worked yeah and it worked and
i'm grateful for it but now it's time to
show [ __ ]
that i you know i can rap man he can't
put me on a [ __ ] list with uh
you know to shocker or or snow or
what you know no the informers know no
you're not not snow from uh
texas uh
informer informer yeah that's no yeah
i don't even i don't even is he a rapper
i don't think he's a rapper i think they
were just high
who's your top three
bizarre who's your top your top three
worst rappers of all time
my top three worst rappers of all time
oh my god let me think about that
oh
i'm gonna i'll give you mine just okay
yeah
to me
playboy cardi is [ __ ] god-awful okay
i don't get it saw him live it sounded
like he was having a [ __ ] seance on
stage
his fans are crazy it can be the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
playboy cardi has definitely taken the
cake for me
i think technically speaking
i mean
i enjoyed soaked the shockers and music
vastly but
when you go back and listen now you're
like oh
that was interesting
and then you got to start thinking about
guys like uh
little xan
damn what was that little zam's terrible
oh man
what is it just you just don't
understand him no no i get the like he
had one record that was dope okay okay
but his [ __ ] sucks
he's stack quote will tell you his [ __ ]
sucks and he wants
that quote yeah
damn his [ __ ] was like he he just never
was focused enough to like make music a
priority so the music that i uh outside
of that skittle song like god this
thought he was just a god off of ours
damn i'm trying to think of a god offer
already man
you you think anybody i'm trying to
think of somebody so many people
what about anybody from like a rapper's
crew i'm trying to think who was a part
of qbc oh surprise
really horrible horrible okay yeah we're
gonna put the horrible tag on prize yeah
okay
surprise
yeah
no disrespect though
i know you're probably gonna come after
me i don't want to battle there was the
uh who was the guy who was naz's
bodyguard
big hawk big record horse
yep horse
bodyguard
he's a horse's wack
was there someone in murdering
is it murdery
i don't know you know what though
there was some shitty rappers back in
the day man there were some bad
yeah i think we i think i think sophie
shocker suffices for for my 90s
you gonna go with the shocker like that
i had a no limit chain too so it hurts
me oh
i don't know man
it was for mystical the chain was from
no the chain was for ghetto dope
that was hey shout out to master p yeah
maybe not the best rapper i'm just
trying to think of who else classic
album though
love gear
too yeah yeah charge it to the game
great yeah i mean listen
is whack i'm just saying he was [ __ ]
maya so we can't even give him that he
was [ __ ] maya in 99 so yeah shout out
to no i said it so you can't say it but
yeah yeah damn you can see it yeah so
who can you say um anybody from
psychopath records it was just terrible
how about the whole [ __ ] label i said
jesus christ
camp is on a roll right now
you know what though
i'm gonna be honest all right i didn't
listen to a lot of that [ __ ] my cousins
were into that [ __ ] so maybe i just am
not versed enough but i know some of
that [ __ ] like
my cousin would be listening to like a
blazer dead homie album or something and
it just sounded like noise like bad
noise like it sounded like if my dad
tried to rap type [ __ ] you know oh my
god
there was the other guy who was like the
native dude with like the braids
oh abk
just terrible oh my god just terrible
twist is cool right there all right yeah
yeah twist is cool but i said he had
some cool [ __ ] you know great malenko
was like the only album i think i've
ever really listened to and it was like
it was all right
but yeah now those are pretty much like
everyone who wasn't twisted or icp on
psychopathic records we could probably
let me google
the worst 50 rappers and see what
there's a list that just came out
it is am i on it again
[Laughter]
it just went viral i just saw it
uh new list oh this is
here it is
worst rappers list
so little yachties on it yeah lil
yachty's not garbage i love little
yachty silk the shocker's number one
i'm opening it
oh yeah so i'm opening it right now okay
little yachty number two that's [ __ ]
cap
master p3 oj the juice man
[ __ ] little flip cap little flick
could wrap his ass off yep
little pump there's an argument to be
made yeah definitely smoke perp argument
to be made
six nine
arguments i would say he's terrible he
made some bangers diddy's on here
walk a flock of that's [ __ ] coiler
ray birdman
birdman has too much music that he's
rapping on that i actually thoroughly
enjoy
vanilla ice
kid boo
god awful rapper who's kid boo he's the
guy who pretended like he was cloned in
some cloud era rap [ __ ] it was terrible
yeet
you know what
the worst rapper of all time might be
yeet
this new kid yeet his [ __ ] is
horrible but the kids love them so maybe
i'm old benzino
benzino
how do we not think of him
i never listened to his music nobody did
[Laughter]
blue face cardi little b
you should do with nick kenny oh no nick
cannon that's my dog man i can't say no
comment yeah yeah you won't get them a
while now i'm gonna wanna see nick
cannon [ __ ]
though saint luna chicks
iggy
iggy azalea maybe designer maybe no
designer anyway
he's not not white yeah he alright yeah
i ain't gonna put him in the wac
category
french montana yeah you ain't twins mike
jones little uzi flow rider slash pit
bull
this list is crazy this list don't know
what they talking about petey pablo okay
gucci mane relax
exactly
tony yayo relax i love thoughts of a
pretty good feeling tom mcdonald who is
that he's the white guy the maga rapper
i'll sign i'll cosign that
actually there's a lot of weird like
maga rap going on right now that's
probably the worst [ __ ] ever so
i would i would just like to continue my
beef with these guys and say what adam
calhoun
and all those guys are the worst rappers
of all time
the absolute worst
i see a list of uh come back come at me
in the comments bro they got a little be
on this [ __ ] weirdos
little b
the bass guy who can't disrespect the
bass guys
he'll put a curse on us
gutta gutter
gotta gutter from uh from young money
was actually not a bad rapper
uh i would i would say silk i mean
literally i would say something shocker
is is
you're not on this list
yeah i must step my game up a little bit
the album works
i think we off the list they got playboy
cardio in here
yeah playboy cardi they got nelly on
here yeah nellie's incredible relax iggy
i get it you can't put future on this
list future's one of the best rappers of
all time in my opinion yeah somebody
just made up a list somebody at home
with nothing to do man